at all often. Excommunicated by
the rest of the tribes of
Quresh and by extension, the
rest of those in the Arab
Peninsula. That is because
Quraish had very strong ties
and far-reaching political
relationships with most, if not
all of the tribes of the Arab
Peninsula. And so,
After this, they spent about 3
years there in that Sheb. What
is known as Sheb, Abia Talib,
or the Valley,
Abu Talib. They remain there
for 3 years enduring hunger and
famine and hardship. After
this, due to a prophecy, that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
provided the prophet they were
able to come out of exile and
rejoin the rest of their and
the rest of their people in
Quresh and live there again.
Abu Talib did not relent
Abu Talib did not relent and he
refused to hand over the
prophet
and
stated in no uncertain
terms that he believed.
Muhammad his nephew was in fact
a prophet from Allah and a
messenger. Everything that he
was saying and calling to was
correct and truthful. And
accurate. However he did not
accept Islam. And did not
adhere as a Muslim. Due to his
fear of the social
repercussions of doing so.
and this articulates to us the
true nature of belief. The true
nature of belief. When we say
for instance and we discuss
this at the beginning of this
book.
When we say belief amen.
Belief has a linguistic meaning
to it and it has a legislative
Islamic Islamic meaning to it.
It's linguistic meaning is
positive belief, unwavering
belief. However, it's
legislative meaning as we've
mentioned,
belief in the heart, and
adherence of the tongue, ad
herence of actions, it
increases with Allah's
obedience, and decreases with
Allah's disobedience. This is
belief as expressed to us by
Allah and his messenger. In the
Quran and in the Sunnah. So
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says belief, when the prophet
says belief, this is what he is
referring to
We see here that Abu Talib
believed in the linguistic
sense. Meaning, he acknowledged
that the prophet was truthful
and his claim to prophethood
but he was indeed sent by Allah
and then the Quran he recited
were was is the words of Allah.
However, he died as a non
Muslim. He did not accept
Islam. Because it is not enough
to merely believe in one's
heart. Say, well, you know, in
my heart of hearts, I believe
that this is true. Without ad
hering, and having a general
attitude of ad herence. Having
a general attitude of, Allah is
my Lord, the prophet is my
messenger. I must obey in a
general holistic sense. This is
what belief is referring to
the Quran and in the sunnah. So
Abu Talib according to the
consensus of the scholarship of
Islam is not a Muslim. He never
was. He never accepted Islam.
Even though he stated many
places through his poetry,
through things that were.
Narrated to have said, for him
narrated that he had said, he
expressed his belief and
acknowledgement of the
prophet's message. What he
refused to follow It's
important for us to understand
that this is not enough There
has to be ad herence. There has
to be obedience. There has to
be a holistic sense of
following the prophet
and so,
had never accepted Islam but he
was a great asset to the
prophet as were the tribes of
the messengers and prophets
throughout time. They were sent
from the best of tribes. The
prophets and messengers were
anointed and chosen from the
best of tribes. And as they
deliver their message their
tribes would usually protect
them. Would usually protect
them from the reign of terror
of the prophets antagonist and
so Abu Talib was very crucial,
very critical to the message of
Islam being delivered properly.
The prophet
being able to deliver his
message unadulterated. Abu
Talib provided very crucial
protection for him to do so.
And so the death of Abu Talib
was a huge huge hit to the
prophet It was it marked a
point when there was very
little protection and that
barrier that stood between
himself And his antagonist was
now wearing very thin
He says
So,
[Silence]
sick and passed away six months
after that. This was a huge hit
to the prophet both both
personally and with regards to
his his journey as a prophet in
his Dawah. And so just because
Abu Talib had not accepted
Islam doesn't mean that he was
not loved by the prophet and
when we loved here. We're
speaking about a natural love,
right? There's a difference
between natural love and
religious love. Natural love is
what a person naturally has for
those who do good to them. A
religious love is an
unconditional
it's a love that the only
condition is a person's tie to
them in religion that we share
the same religion. We believe
in the same creator. We worship
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. We
follow the same messenger.
Therefore, I love all of my
Muslim brothers and sisters,
those of them who I've met and
those whom I have not. Con two,
contrary to personal love,
Personal love. This is
something that a person can't
control. If you have a father
figure or you have a personal
love. For that person. And
these two types of love do not
usually clash. However, in the
instance that they do clash,
person's responsibility is to
give residence to their
religious brotherhood. So,
there is blood relations and
there is religious relations.
We are all brothers. We're not
blood brothers. We don't share
the same tribe or the same
father or mother. But we share
the same. We share the same
religion. And so those two
types of love, they're
different.
just the same on the other side
of the fence or on the other
side of the coin, we see that
the non Muslims, those who
antagonized the prophet they
refuse to enter into Islam and
they antagonize the prophet
they loved him in a personal
way. right? He was known as
being someone who was very
trustworthy and someone who's
very upright and someone that
had no quarrel with anybody.
and he was someone that people
trusted with their wealth,
people trusted with their
blood. And so, the people of
Quraish in general, all loved
the prophet but that love was a
personal love. It wasn't a
religious love. And that is why
it is not considered rewarding
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It's natural. It's not
religious and so, what a person
is rewarded for is religious
love. That is something that
they did not have for the
prophet rather they had
personal love, natural love.
And so Abu Talib passing away
was a very big deal. It was
prophet took quite a hit and
took that to heart very much
so. However, it was not over
yet. The calamities were coming
in quick succession. He says
after Abu Talib passed away,
his wife and confidant and ad
vocate and supporter, Khadijah,
the mother of all of his
children, Barb one, passed
away. She passed away three
days after Abu Talib. and
that's why this year
specifically, the tenth year is
referred to as this is not what
the prophet called it. It's
it's just a term that is used
amongst historians, Islamic
historians as Am the year of
sadness. Why? Because the
prophet
lost Abu Talib and then right
after that Khadijah. Now Abu
Talib's lost was arguably more
painful to the prophet than
Khadijah. Why is that? Because
he lost Abu Talib in this life
and the hereafter. He refused
to enter Islam. He died as a
non Muslim and he chose the
path of hell. Knowingly. This
meant that he was he had
committed himself to eternal
damnation and this is something
that troubled the prophet very
very much. Khadijah, he had
lost her in this life, not in
the hereafter, in the
hereafter. It would be reunited
and so forth. But Abu Talib,
his loss was very much severe.
Some of the scholars say that
the timeline was a little bit
different. Meaning that Abu
Talib passed away and Khadijah
passed away three days later.
Some say a few weeks or months
later. But we do know that they
all agree that both Abu Talib
and Khadijah passed away in
this year. And in quick
succession. Adijah was had a
very specific particular
position in the prophet esteem.
She was his first wife. He was
the mother of all of his
children except for Ibrahim.
The prophet had 8 children. And
Khadijah, was the mother to all
seven out of those eight. To
seven out of those eight.
Last of those children was
Ibrahim. and Ibrahim passed
away very very young and that
was from his concubine Maria.
Had a very particular place.
Very particular place in the
prophet esteem. It was his
first wife, the mother of his
children, from amongst his
wives. She was the first
believer of all the Muslims and
the first to believe in him.
And she was his first ad vocate
and true companion. So when we
say the companions of the
prophet
she was the first Sahabi. She
was the first Muslim after the
prophet at one point Khadijah
was half of the Muslim Ummah.
Right? Half of the Muslim
Ummah, the prophet was the
other half. And very similar,
was her position with the
prophet as that of Sarah with
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. There's a
narration in Sahih Muslim. In
which Ibrahim left his people
after they attempted to kill
him, burn him alive. that when
he left and made this hijra,
this migration
he said to his wife, there is
noone on this earth, a believer
today, except for you and me,
right? So, at one point, there
were only two believers on the
Earth and Sodo was one of
those. So, she was half of the
Muslim Ummah at that time. And
very similarly, was this
position that she shared with
the prophet
Khadijah is considered to be a
We know that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala placed the Muslims, his
servants, his obedient servant.
He gave them different ranks.
Four ranks. A loss of Allah
said Rasul.
he mentions subhanahu wa ta
[Silence]
After that, are the martyrs,
the Shohadad. And after that,
the rest of the righteous what
is a so we see that Abu Bakr is
often referred to as Omar, an
earthman, and Ali. All three of
them. Or Shuaid. They were
murdered for the sake of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. All three
of them. All three of them were
killed by another. due to their
position However, Abu Bakr was
a and Abu Bakr was a Shahid as
well which is something that
many people don't know about
Abu Bakr.
We
didn't mention it Yet, we
haven't arrived at that point
yet when Abu Bakr makes Hijra
with the prophet
However, It's mentioned by many
historians and many scholars
that Abu Bakr when he made
Hijra with the prophet
they stopped off and took
refuge in a cave. Known as
when they hid in this cave,
there were open holes for
different types of animals.
Snakes and lizards and
scorpions and stuff. And so Abu
Bakr who first went into the
cave. to prepare it and make it
safe. and so, it's mentioned
that he took much of his
garment that he was wearing and
began to stuff these holes,
ripping pieces off of his stove
and stuffing these holes so
that when the prophet came in,
there would be a little threat
of him being stung or bitten.
to mention that there was one
final hole and again, they went
into this cave in haste. They
were hiding in there and they
had to remain there for 3 days.
The prophet came in and there
was one whole remaining which
Abu Bakr plugged with his foot,
with his heel, the heel of his
foot. and there happened to be
a venomous snake in there and
its bit Abu Bakr on his foot.
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wa
Sallam later spit into this
wound and Abu Bakr was healed
from it. Which what we find out
is that this actually didn't
reverse the venom but rather it
but rather it paused it because
after the prophet died, Abu
Bakr began to be get very sick.
And in some narrations, Abu
Bakr states that this is the
venom of that snake after the
prophet passed away. It began
to take hold in his body.
Abu Bakr wrote the was a Sudiq.
Khadijah was a what is a in the
Arabic language is taken from
the root word which is Assad,
this articulates, belief, and
trustworthiness. When Allah
refers to him as
our articulates and exaggerated
portion of belief that is
unwavering. Meaning that he
believed in the prophet
and
never experienced a moment
of doubt. Never a flash of
doubt. In Abu Bakr's heart.
This is a and this is why a has
the highest level, highest
ranking is held in highest
esteem after the prophets and
messengers, the highest rank a
human being can have with Allah
short of prophethood as a is a
and that is incredibly rare and
incredibly difficult for a
person to earn that level of
belief that they believe in
their respective profit so
deeply, so intensely, so
immediately that not a
momentary flash of doubt is
something they have ever
experienced. Is considered a
and this is the meaning of that
title. scholars differ on the
virtue of Khadijah as opposed
to the virtue of Aisha.
When the prophet was asked as
is in Sahih in a man who is
most beloved to you amongst
people. He said We understand
this to be of his living wives.
Most beloved to him. Now, the
scholars differ on who holds a
higher rank and virtue from
amongst between and Khadijah.
Some scholars view it to be
Aisha. Due to the depth of her
knowledge. Others view it to be
Khadijah. Due to thee, virtues
mentioned by the prophet one of
those virtues is that Khadijah
was conveyed a salaam from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
we mentioned that the previous
classes is a very high virtue,
very few of the companions
received this salutation
directly from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. and Imam is of the
view that Khadijah is holds
higher virtue than Aisha.
[Arabic recitation]
it would seem that if we were
to take all of the virtues
mentioned in the sunnah and in
the Quran as well of Khadijah
or of Aisha. It would seem that
Khadijah's virtues exceed those
of Aisha. However, it's
something that holds very
little bearing in the
greater picture and that is
that both Khadijah and Aisha
were of the most blessed, pure,
women in the history of
mankind.
Said
So, as we mentioned, that
barrier between
[Silence]
most elite and notables of
Quresh and so, every time that
Abu Jahil, Abu Lahab, his own
uncle, others,
Omega Ibn Khalef, obey Ibn
Khalef. When these characters
would attempt to harm the
prophet would conspire to kill
him. They would be stopped by
Abu Talib. And Abu Talib was
considered very respected and
in some
In some aspects, very feared in
Quraish. It was not going to
happen that anyone was going to
harm the prophet in any
meaningful way as long as Abu
Talib was alive. He refused to
hand him over and he refused to
allow anyone to harm him. But
when Abu Talib died, that
protective barrier between the
prophets
and his antagonist became very
thin. And so now
the people of Quresh, his
antagonist, they ramped up the
aggression towards the prophet
and his companions.
Now, the strategy had to change
At first, he was in Mecca. Abu
Talib was protecting him. He
was able to convey the message
of Allah with relative
impunity. Now that Abu Talib
passed away, the strategy had
to change now. Because it was
something that was eventual
that they would conspire to
kill him. There's a very
important difference between a
prophet and a messenger. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
the Quran prophets and he
mentions messengers. And he
differentiates between the two.
When we look at the verses of
the Quran, we look at the
narrations of the prophet and
how these two words are used.
And the the the definitions
they are rendered. We see that
there is a difference between a
prophet and a messenger. The
majority of the scholarship of
Islam is of opinion that every
messenger is a prophet but not
every prophet is a messenger.
Let's repeat that. Every
messenger is a prophet. But not
every prophet is a messenger.
Meaning that we have
prophethood and a level above
that is messengership. There
are many things in the Quran,
many things in the Sunnah that
articulate this. One of them is
a narration of Abudar.
It's a well-known narration
collected in a and also in
Ahmed. In which the prophet was
asked, how many messengers were
sent? and he said, three
hundred and fifteen Three
hundred and fifteen messengers
in the history of mankind from
Adam Alaihi Salam to the last
of the messengers, Muhammad
there were three hundred and
fifteen. And then he was asked
and how many prophets He said
So there is a big difference
between a messenger and a
prophet. Out of that hundred
and twenty-three thousand, only
three hundred andfifteen were
elected by Allah to be
messengers. Now, what's the
real main difference, the
practical difference between a
prophet and a messenger? The
real difference between a
prophet and a messenger is who
they are sent to, right? A
prophet is usually sent as a
reviver, and a someone who the
torch is passed down to. by
another messenger. So, usually
a prophet is fulfills the role
kind of the companions
filled that role of the prophet
Muhammad He disseminated his
knowledge to them and they
carried that knowledge after
him and kept it pure. A
messenger is usually is always
sent to a people who are not
Muslim. They are usually
idolaters. They worship other
than Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and they are usually an
aggressive people that
fundamentally differ with their
messenger. When we look at the
Musa, Isa, Alaihi Salam,
Shuaib, who would, all of these
prophets and messengers, all of
these messengers that were
mentioned in the Quran, we see
that they were all sent to an
aggressive, disbelieving
people. Contrary to prophets,
prophets are usually sent as
revivers. They're usually sent
as revivers. There is another
critical difference between
prophets and messengers. That
is that messengers not be
killed by their people Notice
what I'm saying here. A
messenger is sent to a
disbelieving people.
this messenger is the
representative of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and the of
Allah. this messenger will not
ever be killed, has never been
killed by his people. You may
say, well, we know a lot of
prophets that are killed. Say,
those are prophets that were
killed. Zechariah, Yahia, and
many of these stories that we
know where the prophet, a
prophet would be killed and
murdered by his people. That's
very common. However, a
messenger in the legislative
meaning is protected by Allah
from being murdered because he
articulates the throughout his
life as a messenger he has to
fulfill and completely convey
the message of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala as a as a collective
whole completed religion right
and so messengers when they are
to a people either the people
believe and their messenger
dies amongst them, a natural
death, or they disbelieve, and
they are destroyed by Allah.
This is a main difference
between messengers and
prophets. the messenger of
Allah Muhammad was protected by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala with
very in various ways. It's not
just some magical, mystical
protection. Allah protected him
through his tribe. Allah
protected him through the Allah
protected him through his
companions. But nonetheless
protected. Right? Because he
had to convey and fulfill the
entirety of the religion of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now,
when his uncle Abu Talib passed
away, that aggression was
becoming more and more intense
His antagonists were becoming
more and more brazen and his
shield and barriers protection
became very thin. So now, he
decided to change strategy into
go to another tribe or another
city, another place and have
the people of that place except
Islam and protect him from his
own people. And he chose a and
so he walked there to
convey the message of Islam to
its elders. And to bargain with
them. To take him in as their
messenger and protect him as
the later would.
He says
the